for you how exciting is it to bring aew
a promotion that you're very involved
with not just as an on-screen talent but
behind the scenes to your hometown as aw
continues to expand well it's amazing
because the Genesis of aw happened
basically because of Winnipeg Tokyo Dome
2018 was Jericho versus Omega headlining
the the the Russell Kingdom and the
match was basically brokered by Don
Callas so three winnipeggers uh put on
this match that did huge business
worldwide from streaming and
pay-per-view and actually in Japan
itself as well so that was kind of the
where Tony Khan realized that there was
a market for for an alternative in pro
wrestling and that's what really kind of
kick-started him to to want to start aew
so it's very apropos that we come to
Winnipeg even though it's only our
second uh Canadian city Toronto of
course being the first but Winnipeg
should be uh you know the in the in the
top two when it comes to just the
lineage of aw
not to mention the fact that Winnipeg is
such a great pro wrestling City and I
think it's going to be just a crazy
night all across the board not just for
the people in the crowd but for the
people watching at home because there's
something about winnipeggers like when
the Jets play in the playoffs it's the
loudest building in the entire league
louder than Chicago louder than New York
so I think the the the pro wrestling
world is in for a treat when they see
our first show uh in Winnipeg plus
showcasing Kenny Omega and showcasing
Chris Jericho in our first aw
appearances in in our hometown so it's
going to be one of those magical nights
and pro rest if it happens only when all
the stars line up and on Wednesday the
stars have lined up for sure
it's I mean in so many ways you have a
rare sort of entering encounter with the
elite and Jericho Appreciation Society
the two winnipeggers house of black who
have become a very popular group among
the aw audience what is it about the
Canadian crowds that's so raucous
because I feel like anytime promotion
comes north of the Border well crowd
reaction yeah man but it's not all
Canadian crowds though it's not all
Canadians Winnipeg Toronto Edmonton are
all really really crazy
um it's just like the states some cities
are crazier than others it's not just
going to Canada you're instantly going
to have a Nutty crowd but
um I I think once again the fact that aw
is heading Canada for the first time I'm
expecting all the crowds uh to be nuts
for us because it's the first time but
but Winnipeg is a different level it
really is and it always has been not
just because Chris Jericho's in town I
mean when I was a kid going to the
wrestling matches it was always you know
people going crazy and going nuts and
all that sort of things so I mean the
last time I was on TV from Winnipeg was
was raw 2004 and I was in a Musical
Chairs match of all things which I won
uh so for me to be in a title match this
is also this is Kenny's first arena show
in Winnipeg and it's my first arena show
match in Winnipeg the only time there's
ever been television from from Winnipeg
was like I said that the the the the the
um musical chairs master I think I had a
match later on that night but but it
wasn't the same once you're out there
people see you and then you come out
again and it's kind of like okay it's
good but so I think I think we wanted to
put together something special not just
for Winnipeg not just for Canada but for
everybody that watches aw which we do
every week because like I said it's one
of those special nights when you've got
not just one not just two but three
Hometown Heroes who were very much
involved in aw between myself Kenny and
Don Callis so I I'm excited for it I
think it's gonna be one of those like I
mentioned a really magical night for for
not just aw for all wrestling fans in
general
I'll make sure to add musical chairs to
this yeah add that to the list next time
please yeah
um you know you take such uh so much
pride it seems in the work you do with
uh guiding and preparing and working
with the young stars of aw just came out
of a program with Ricky Starks who I
think many of us have earmarked as one
of the Futures mjf another one I want to
kind of flip that on its head a bit what
is one thing one lesson big or small
that you've learned from one of the
younger wrestlers on the roster that
really blew you away
well I don't think I don't think one
wrestling when I came back to WWE in
um I had no interest in wrestling with
with Sean Michaels or Triple H or
Undertaker of those guys because even
though they're all the best the best I'd
done that already and I didn't want
Chris Jericho to turn in kind of like
the seniors tour
um I thought it would be really smart to
work with younger guys so they get the
rub from me in return I get the rub from
then that's if you look at that run with
Kevin Owens and Sami Zayn and Roman
Reigns and Seth Rollins all the guys who
are on top now were just kind of
bubbling over the surface and I think
working with me kind of helped them get
to the next step and plus it helped me
kind of learn you know the old dog new
tricks analogy you know there's a lot of
guys who say well you know in the in the
90s you would never do this the 2000s
you would never do this well guess what
those days are gone it's 2023 and you
have to wrestle the style that people
want to see now but also incorporate the
experience that you have so when I'm
working with you know you mentioned mjf
or Ricky Starks or orange Cassidy or
jungle boy or you know all these guys
Danny Garcia the list goes on and on and
on of guys that have worked with Eddie
Kingston that you know it keeps me in
the mix at a top level but it's not like
it it it hinders anything because I'm
also learning the style of today but
combining that with the experience that
I have on how to put together a match we
just had a crazy match on Wednesday with
Sammy and Danny versus Top Flight and AR
Fox it was unbelievable that the amount
of lettuce athleticism was off the
charts but what I brought to the table
was where to put it when to do it and
how it can make the most impact and
that's kind of what I think it's a great
combination of the two I don't want to
work with Matt Hardy or Christian in aw
not that they're not amazingly legendary
performers because they are but we've
seen that 20 years ago let's work with
some of these younger guys now and and
put on matches that you've never seen
I've never been in the ring with
Aleister black or Brodie King and not to
mention I haven't been in the ring with
Matt Nick and Kenny for three years so
it's a fresh new match with all
generations and everybody in the ring is
just a tremendous wrestler and
tremendous character I think it has
potential to be one of the all-time
classics for aw and in pro wrestling
history
um it's been so exciting seeing aw enter
this market and and offer an alternative
program it's still a very young company
and so what I would like from you is two
things one where is an area of
improvement you think aw can make and
then on the second question is where
does aw continue to really Excel well I
mean I think improving is the fact that
we've gone so big in three and a half
years so there's a lot of growing pains
as we expected there would be I don't
think anyone thought that we'd be doing
the numbers that we're doing both in the
Arenas and and ratings-wise and that was
to be expected so obviously we're
working on our infrastructure working on
all that sort of thing behind the scenes
on building the corporate side of aew
um you know and everybody's learning how
to be on live TV still and and it really
is just
everyone was thrown into the deep end
and had to react accordingly you know
and I've been very proud of everybody
that's been able to do that yeah we've
had some bumps on the road but that's
expected it's Pro rusting you know and
plus like I said it'd become a major
television entity in a very short period
of time
um and what do we do great I I just
think there's there's no other wrestling
company in the world that puts on a show
like AAW as far as just being kind of an
all-around
Smorgasbord if you will of pro wrestling
Styles if you look at our last paper
Revolution which I think is one of the
best papers you've ever done you start
off with Jericho and Ricky Starks in a
pro wrestling match what a concept then
you got a final burial match with
Christian and jungle boy which is off
the charts and you got an amazing
six-man match with the elite in the
house of black then you got a Texas
Death Match with Mox and Daniel or Max
and uh and uh is uh Adam page and then
you got the 60 Minute Iron Man classic
with mjf and Danielson those are five
distinctly different matches and all of
them were amazing you won't find that on
any other wrestling show in any other
company it's what we do best so I think
we just continue to do aw and improve
upon that I think our production has
gotten so much better over the last
month or so we got a new director named
Mike mansuri who's just really made a
big difference as far as replays and the
way things are shot all that stuff make
you appear more uh gigantic and all
those little things and those little
things matter in the ring and outside
the ring you've done so many great
things in your career what is one of the
more most sort of creatively satisfying
moments of your career that just kind of
pops out when I ask that question I mean
I think just joining aw
um this is right off the bat I mean it
was took it was a little bit of a risk
to come here you know I could have
stayed and WB and been comfortable for
for the rest of my career and if I'd
done that I don't know if I'd still be
wrestling today because I was very just
meant to like yeah whatever uh aw kind
of reignited the passion and reign of my
creative my creativity uh took things to
the next level all across the board I
think 2022 was a career year for uh for
me as a result
um and all the creative elements that we
brought to the table I think the
year-long feud that mjf and Chris
Jericho had was was amazing I think you
go back to when Moxley beat me for the
title to become the second ever Champion
with the patch over his eye when I
stabbed him with one of the spikes from
my jacket I thought that was pretty cool
even during the pandemic when I worked
with orange Cassidy which is one of the
greatest feuds that nobody ever saw live
because there was no people there that
ended up in the Mimosa Mayhem match you
look at that and go oh that's so corny
but at the time it fit perfectly he's
orange juice I'm bubbly putting together
and it's almost like a like a fmw
exploding uh land mine match but you got
to fall into a pit of mimosa that was
awesome the stadium stampedes that we
did during the pandemic were awesome I I
think the lockdown gave you two choices
either
curl up and die or get creative to keep
the show going and keep the show great
and we were able to do there's a lot of
great creativity during that time and I
think the stadium Stampede both of the
one and two both Stand Out amazingly and
then kind of his bastard child the
Anarchy in the arena that we had last
year in Vegas that was amazing no one
knew what to expect with that we didn't
have a clue what we're doing and then
you watched it back and it was one of
the best matches of the year because we
just went out there and just went with
our guts the production team was the
stars of the show because they followed
everything but we had a great great
moment with that as well so there's been
a lot of very creative elements that I'm
proud of in aw for sure